everyone Peter Brown here with another
gamespot news update somebody else is
praising the PlayStation 4's power this
time it's watchdogs dev Ubisoft Colin
Graham animation director of watchdogs
has said that the PlayStation 4 gives
him an almost unlimited memory budget
allowing the creation of richly detailed
and immersive worlds of course this was
an interview on the PlayStation Blog so
the focus on PlayStation 4 is expected
Graham also said PlayStation 4 really
has given us the platform to build a new
type of game it gave us a chance to
dream and from an animation point of
view we're always running out of memory
so playstation 4 allowed things like
reduced animation compression and more
variety in civilians watchdogs lead
gameplay designer Danny Bellinger also
offered a round of praise for the
technical prowess of the ps4 he said the
powerful technology helped us create a
better simulation the water affects the
number of people in the city the quality
of the lighting it all brings us a step
forward there's been a lot of attention
on watch dogs lately first perceived
drop in graphical quality but we still
don't know what systems it's been demo
done still for all your watchdogs news
stay tuned to gamespot com thanks for
watching